[Musik]
das ganze
ehrenzug pressen
zur Meldung an der Militär Quanten das
ganze rechts schaut
herr Präsident Draht meldet die
Militärmusik Steiermark die
Ehrenformation gestellt durch das
Insignia Trupp und die Ehrenformation
des ehrenzuges durch das
Aufklärungssatelliten die Anzug
geloberten Rekruten der ABC
abwehrkomponierte stabspartei und 7 die
erste aufklärungscompanie und zweite
Panzer bis Batterie des aufklärungs 7
sowie die erste ehekompany und
ku-kompanie des jägerpartements 18 in
einer Gesamtstärke von 421 Anzug
gelobten Rekruten sowie die Abordnungen
des ÖKB der Kameradschaft vom Edelweiss
und es fällt jägerpartei uns Nummer 9
zur feierlichen Angelobung und dem 60
Jahre Jubiläum der Kaserne Feldbach
angetreten
jawohl mit dem Festakt fortfahren
[Musik]
das ganze
ehrenzug
Gewehr ab
das ganze
hab acht
ehrenzug
Pressen wird
Flagge hissen
zur flagparade das ganze rechts schaut
[Musik]
das ganze
habt
ehrenzug Gewehr
ob das Ganze rot
bitte wenn Sie die Plätze entnehmen
wir sind ja live drauf und wir begrüßen
hier natürlich alle zu Hause sind vor
dem Bildschirmen und diese Angelobung
live mittlere herzlich willkommen euer
Applaus hier aus Feldbach schön dass Sie
zu Hause dabei sind
[Applaus]
13.331 Einwohner hat diese schöne neue
Stadt das ist die fünf größte Stadt der
Steiermark und seit 2015 ist an der
Spitze wir freuen uns in hier begrüßen
zu dürfen Bürgermeister der
Stadtgemeinde Feldbach hier Ingenieur
Josef ober
[Applaus]
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren ich
darf Sie namens der neuen Stadt Feldbach
herzlichst einen wunderschönen Abend
hier am Kirchenplatz der Stadt Feldbach
begrüßen und willkommen heißen
ich freue mich dass nach
einer doch sehr dürftigen Probezeit ist
wieder möglich ist angelogen mit der
Öffentlichkeit gemeinsam mit der
Garnisonstadt durchzuführen herzlichen
Dank dafür zu diesem besonderen Anlass
darf ich heute Frau Landesrätin Doktorin
Juliane Bogner Strauß aufs herzlich
begrüßen ich freue mich dass du da bist
ich begrüße auf das Herzlichste die
Abgeordnete zum Nationalrat Magister
Minister Doktorin Agnes Dotter
stellvertretend für alle Abgeordneten
zum Landtag begrüße ich den
regierungsvorsitzenden Abgeordneten
franz fatek
ich begrüße den Militärkommandanten von
Steiermark brigidier Heinz Söllner und
ich danke ihm dass das in Feldbach in so
schönem Rahmen möglich geworden ist sehr
herzlich gegrüßt
von den Behörden darf ich begrüßen die
stellvertreterde bezirkshauptfrau rosa
Marco
von den Einsatzorganisationen darf ich
begrüßen von der Polizei major Joachim
Kleinschuster
von der Freiwilligen Feuerwehr den Abi
Hannes
und von Roten Kreuz den Ort stehen
Leiter Fabian Fladischer
von der Geistlichkeit begrüße ich
herzlich für die römische katholische
Kirche mit Militärpfarrer Johannes
Freitag
und unserem Pfarrer Förderantrag
von der Wirtschaft begrüße und darf im
merzigs gratulieren zu diesen
fulminanten Auftritt im Fernsehen Herrn
Honorarkonsul madias Magister Andreas
[Applaus]
verantwortlich und Leiter für die
operative Einsatzführung
herrenbrikettier Herbert Sailer der Herz
ist Gerüst
den stellvertretenden Kommandanten der 7
jägerbrigade Herrn Oberst Bernhard köfl
den Kommandanten des aufklärungs
Satellit Bataillon 7 und den heutigen
Kommandanten der ausgerückten Truppe als
Feldbach Herrn oberstleitner Rath
denn Kommandanten des jägerpetalons 18
aus St Michael oberstes Generalstabes
Magister Klaus schadenbauer
den ehemaligen Kommandanten des
aufklärungssatteriebataillon 7 Herrn
Brigadier in Ruhe Rainer Karasek
den ehemaligen Kommandanten des
aufklärungsatteriebatterien 7 schoning
sie den ehemaligen Kommandanten des
Jägerbataillons 17er Straße ein Brigitte
in Ruhe Josef Paul Puntigam
von den Vereinen darf ich begrüßen den
Präsidenten der
unteroffiziersgesellschaft Steiermark
kann Vize Leutnant Andreas Mattausch
sowie für die Offiziersgesellschaft
Steiermark Herrn Brigadier alles
Hirschmugl
die Kameraden des österreichischen
Kameradschaftsbundes mit Vizepräsident
Franz Funkel und Obmann Karl Buchgraber
stellvertretend für den Stadt und
Gemeinderat
Herrn ersten Vizebürgermeister Christian
orthoff
für alle Ehrenbürger der Stadt und
ehrenzeichenträger darf ich
stellvertretend für alle Anwesenden
Bürgermeister aus der Dienst den
Ehrenbürger und Bürgermeister
ausserdienst Anton Schuh begriffen
ich begrüße herzlichst die Militärmusik
Steiermark und Leitung von
Militärkapellmeister Oberst Magister
Magister dr Professor Johannes Lackner
und unsere Atelier traditionskapelle von
der Gröben mit Kapellmeister Franz
kerschhofer die uns einbegleitet haben
aber vor allem begrüße ich die lieben
Rekruten die hier vor der Villa holt
Aufstellung genommen haben mit ihren
Eltern Familien allen Besuchern und
Besuchern sein Sie herzlichst willkommen
in der neuen Stadt Feldbach
heutigen angelogen
wenn sich als sich als Bürger wer sich
als Bürger in der Demokratie beheimatet
wer sie wertschätzt und bereit ist sie
zu verteidigen wird sie erhalten wollen
für sich für die eigenen Kinder und für
die nachfolgenden Generationen ein
Spruch von Johann Gauck jemanden
Bundespräsidenten Deutschlands für mich
ein ganz berührender Spruch weil er
heute stellvertretend für die Rekruten
die angelobt werden gilt ich danke euch
für den Dienst
für die Republik für die Sicherheit die
ihr damit uns Menschen die Bürgern
dieser Republik auch gibt
eine feierliche Angelobung ist ein
besonderer Akt der heute hier gemeinsam
vollzogen wird ich danke nochmals dass
es hier in der Stadt Feldbach der
kommissionsstadt stattfinden darf und
freue mich dass wir das auch zum Anlass
nehmen können das vorige Jubiläum
Gründung der Kaserne 1960
heuer mit dem 60-jährigen Jubiläum
nachvollziehen können
ich
darf den kasernenkommandanten zu mir
bitten
ich bitte auch den Herrn
und den
landesmilitärkommandanten zu mir
ich darf damals dann als Stadtfahrten
eine Urkunde verleihen
und ich bitte auch einen ersten
Vizebürgermeister mich zu unterstützen
wir wollen auch ein besonderes Geschenk
dem ersten System
im Jahre 1955 bemühte sich der
Gemeinderat der Stadt Feldbach um einen
kasernenstandort bereits 1957 wurde mit
dem Bau der Kaserne begonnen und am 25
März 160 zogen die ersten Soldaten mit
einer Truppenparade über den Hauptplatz
in die neuaparty-kaserne ein 1963 wurde
die dritte fliegerabwehrbatterie in der
Kaserne aufgestellt und 1967 konnte der
Schießplatz in Kornberg als
Ausbildungsplatz in Betrieb genommen
werden
sukzessive wurde der kasernenstandort
erweitert und modernisiert bis er 2009
zum aufklärungs- und batteriebataillon 7
wurde was enorme Veränderungen mit sich
brachte
2012 wurde die Kaserne zum
Referenzzentrum für das
waffeneinsatzsystem kommt entschieden
mit der Einführung der taktik-computers
für Streitkräfte Betrag unzählige
auslandsgrenze und katastrophensätze
wurden von der kadereinheit des
aufklärungs- und analog 7 unterstützt da
die platznote in der Kaserne immer
größer wurde konnte im heurigen Jahr
endlich mit dem Bau des dritten
mannschaftsblogs begonnen werden die
Neustart feldbrücke gratuliert zum
60-jährigen zu 60 Jahre Kaserne Feldbach
und spricht kasernenkommandant
oberstleitner Magister Günther Rath
stellvertretend für die gesamte
Mannschaft der Kaserne Feldbach für ein
Einsatz zum Wohle und der Sicherheit der
Bevölkerung Dank und Anerkennung aus für
die Stadt Feldbach Bürgermeister und
schöner Josef Hofer
[Applaus]
ich habe noch etwas mitgebracht eine
Chronik darf ich noch übergeben
61 Jahre jung aber trotzdem sehr bewegt
was die wenigsten wissen der heutige
Standort der Kaserne war schon 1914 oder
das größte kriegsgefahrenen Lager der
Monarchie errichtet wurde
Austragungsort militärische Aktivitäten
61 Jahre und die darf diese urkundet
wird dann überreichen ich darf aber auch
der Kaserne und vor allem im besonderen
tierkommandant
das Wahrzeichen der Stadt den
steinernetzen der für Beständigkeit für
richtiges Maß halten steht im reichen
und für die Zukunft alles Gute wünschen
er hat 500 Jahre am Buckel möge der
Standort
das ist eine Feldbach weiterhin blühen
und gedeihen die Rekruten so auszubilden
dass sich die Österreicher wohlfühlen
das Kriege vermieden werden aber die der
Frieden und die Sicherheit durch ihren
Einsatz gewahrt sind darf nochmals
herzliches gratulieren und auf den
beiden den brigadekommandanten und auch
dem landeswelt der Kommandanten noch
eine kleine Symbolik als Andenken
überreichen und für die Zukunft alles
erdenklich Gute wünschen ein herzliches
gekauft es lebe das österreichische
Bundesheer es lebe die Republik
Österreich herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Bürgermeister ich darf
stellvertretend für alle meine Soldaten
der Garnison Feldbach mich recht
herzlich für die netten Worte bedanken
und gleichzeitig auch anmerken dass wir
uns hier in Feldbach sehr wohl fühlen
auch wir haben als Verbundenheit
sogarnisonstarts und speziell auch zu
dir natürlich als garnisons
Bürgermeister ein kleines Präsent
anlässlich der 60 Jahre vorbereitet es
ist dies eine Aufnahme deines
Hauptplatzes der Stadt Feldbach von
unserer Luftaufklärung gemacht ich nehme
mal an du wirst es nicht jetzt gleich
einstecken und mitnehmen können daher
wir präsentieren es jetzt und stellen es
dir nachher für den Empfang im Anschluss
an ein Festakt dann zu herzlichen Dank
für deine Unterstützung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das war der Koral mit dem klingenden
Namen backs wo biscue der Friede sei mit
euch seid ihr darüber zu den Geistlichen
Worten sie werden es in Zukunft werden
sie in öfter bei verschiedenen
Veranstaltungen treffen er hat derzeit
noch die Pfarre St Peter Freienstein die
Pfarre Trofaiach fahre vordernberger
und wir bitten um die Geistlichen Worte
des katholischen Militärseelsorger
militärkaplan Magister Johannes Freitag
herzlich willkommen
Liebe festlich versammelte abendliche
Gemeinschaft
Frau Landesrätin Herr Militärkommandant
Herr Bürgermeister
festliche Gemeinschaft hier in der
Öffentlichkeit inmitten von
Feldbach und mit uns über Livestream
verbunden
vor allem liebe anzugehen
ich stehe auf die
das überlegt man sich wohl sehr gut wenn
man das zusagt
ich stehe auf die ein kurzer Satz im
Dialekt festgehalten ganz wenige
Buchstaben aber mit weitreichenden
Folgen
hinter diesen Worten steht eine Zusage
die der dem oder der sie gilt nicht kalt
lässt schon gar nicht gleichgültig
sondern vielmehr erzeugt diese Zusage
ich stehe zu dir
ein inneres kribbeln
das Gefühl bei einem Menschen daheim zu
sein geborgen
dieses zu einem Menschen stehen
schafft oder vertieft vertrauen
ja zu jemanden zu stehen das wird nicht
einfach so daher gesagt im persönlichen
Leben in Kameradschaft und Freundschaft
in einer Beziehung sondern ist eine
wohlüberlegte Zusage
ein ganz persönliches versprechen
Gelöbnis an einen Menschen
und dieses Versprechen dieses Gelöbnis
kommt heraus aus dem Vertrauen
aus dem sich etwas zutrauen und aus dem
sich gegenseitigen anvertrauen
zu jemandem und so etwas zu stehen kennt
die Dimension die vielleicht nicht
modern aber
unabkömmlich ist die Dimension der
Verlässlichkeit
und dass irgendjemand einmal sagt der
und die
ist sich wirklich treu
ich gelobe dass heute festlich hier in
der Öffentlichkeit gesprochen wird
ist auch ein vertieftes ganz
persönliches und auch gemeinsames
Versprechen des zustehens
und ein Gelöbnis wenn man etwas gelobt
im Leben
wo man niemanden anderen für etwas
verantwortlich machen kann sondern
dieses Wort ganz persönlich selber
spricht
ein Gelöbnis wird nicht so daher gesagt
sondern bringt eine innere Überzeugung
zum Ausdruck
und lässt erfahren
wozu Menschen stehen
was ihre innere Überzeugung ist
was Menschen
was jungen Menschen und Kameraden etwas
wert ist
wofür sie einstehen
im Übungsfall
aber auch im Ernstfall
das Gelöbnis dieser besonderen
arbeitlichen Stunde hier in Feldbach mit
über 400 Rekruten ist also ein
verbindliches dazu stehen
in Gemeinschaft aber auch ein ganz
persönliches
Versprechen an die Gemeinschaft und für
unseren Staat
das soll nicht leichtfertig geschehen
und auch nicht
unüberlegt erfolgen
sondern ein Gelöbnis ein der zustehen
kommt aus einem tiefen Vertrauen in die
Kameradschaft
aus der Bereitschaft sich einzubringen
seinen Teil zum Gelingen des Ganzen zu
leisten
und aus einem bemühen
das andere sich auf mich verlassen
können
dabei gilt es dass uns Mögliche zu tun
aber auch entlastet darauf zu vertrauen
dass ich manches fügt und manches
geführt wird
als Glaubende Menschen sagen wir
dass Gott so manches schützt behütet und
anleitet
und das wünsche ich euch liebe Kameraden
in den nächsten Monaten
wohin der Einsatz auch immer führt
welche Grenzerfahrungen vielleicht parat
stehen
welche tiefen Erfahrungen von
Freundschaft und Kameradschaft
ich wünsche dass Gottes Segen uns
begleite
so möchte ich nun beten
gott deine Liebe hört niemals auf und
darauf vertrauen wir im Leben
lass mich Deine Gegenwart spüren
geheimnisvoll und deinen Willen erkennen
und tun
hilf mir an meinem Platz meinen Teil der
Verantwortung mit einem festen Herz und
einem freundlichen Geist zu tragen
mach mich aufmerksam denen gegenüber mit
denen ich zusammen im Dienst bin und
gemeinsam lebe
lass mich meinen Dienst gewissenhaft in
der Verantwortung meinem Land gegenüber
und den Menschen immer vertrauen tun
wenn ich in Versuchung gerate hilf mir
zu widerstehen
wenn ich einen Fehler mache geht mir den
Mut dazu zu stehen und es neu zu
versuchen
leite mich durch deine geheimnisvolle
Gegenwart und das Hören auf meine innere
Stimme das Gewissen
lass mir dabei Jesus ein Beispiel sein
in dessen Namen ich vertraue und bete
Amen
[Musik]
ja ein wunderbares Musikstück
energiegeladen die Zentner Fanfare
Schloss aus der Feder unseres
Militärkapellmeister und der
militärkommunalist der jeweilige
Repräsentant in jeden Bundesland und
seit
2007 für die Geschicke des
österreichischen bundeses hinter
Steiermark und wir freuen uns um seine
Gedanken zur heutigen Angela und
Militärkommandant von Steiermark
herzlich willkommen Herr brikettier
Magister Heinz Söldner
[Applaus]
hochgerehrte Frau Landesrätin
hochgeschätzte Abgeordnete zu dem
Gesetzgeber den Körperschaften
sehr geehrter Herr Bürgermeister
hohe Geistlichkeit
hervorsitzender des Fachausschusses
Steiermark liebe Mitbürgerinnen und
Mitbürger ob hier am Platz oder online
Soldaten Kameraden
als Militärkommandant von Steiermark in
biete ich zunächst allen einen
respektvollen und herzlichen Gruß allen
unseren Ehrengästen den Angehörigen
Freunden unserer Soldaten den
Abordnungen sowie allen Zuschauern die
heute der feierlichen Angelobung unserer
Soldaten hier im Zentrum der
Garnisonstadt Feldbach mitten unter den
Leuten beiwohnern ich danke dem Herrn
Bürgermeister dass wir diese angelogen
heute hier in aller Öffentlichkeit
durchführen können und ich bin froh dass
die aktuelle corona-situation dies auch
unter Einhaltung der gegebenen
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen erlaubt und ich
darf mich beim Bürgermeister für die
diese Vorbereitung in diesem Sinne
herzlich bedanken
gleichzeitig holen wir sozusagen die 60
Jahre Feier da keine so nach zu der ich
herzlich gratuliere und es erfolgt auch
eine Übergabe einer ehrentrompete
angelobt werden heute Soldatinnen und
Soldaten des aufklärungs- und
artillerieparteien 7 hier aus Feldbach
das jägerbad 18 aus St Michael und der
ABC abwehrkomponie des staatsspartillons
7 aus Graz und ihnen möchte ich meinen
besonderen Gruß widmen
meine Damen und Herren
Soldaten als Angelobung bezeichnet man
die Verpflichtung zur gesetzestreuen und
gewissenhaften Ausübung übertragener
Funktionen mit einem feierlichen
versprechen dem Gelöbnis die
gelöbnisformel für das Treuegelöbnis der
Soldatinnen und Soldaten des
Bundesheeres ist im Wehrgesetz
festgelegt und so wird ist die
Ableistung dieses zeuggelöbnisses heute
ein hoheitlicher Akt und die bewusste
und demonstrative Übernahme von
Verantwortung durch die jungen
Soldatinnen und Soldaten gegenüber der
Gemeinschaft und dem Volk der Republik
Österreich
nicht nur Repräsentanten des
öffentlichen Lebens sondern möglichst
große Teile der Bevölkerung und die
Angehörigen da anzugehen Soldatinnen und
Soldaten sollen dies auch bewusst
miterleben können
in wenigen Minuten werden die vor uns
stehenden ihr treuege lebende sprechen
und geloben die Republik Österreich und
das österreichische Volk mit der Waffe
zu verteidigen und wir alle meine Damen
und Herren werden dieses Gelöbnis
stellvertretend für alle
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher
entgegennehmen ein Gelöbnis welches
beide Seiten verpflichten soll und
welches für uns Soldaten auch bedeutet
gegebenenfalls Leid und Leben
einzusetzen
Soldatinnen und Soldaten trotz des
derzeit extrem hohen Einsatz Aufkommens
und der angespannten Budgetlage werden
wir sie bestens auf ihre Aufgaben
vorbereiten und sie bestens und
menschengerecht ausbilden
die Aufgaben des Bundesheeres sind im
Wehrgesetz verankert und überall leisten
sie ihren wichtigen Beitrag sei es in
der militärischen Landesverteidigung sei
es in den assistenzeinsätzen sei es zur
Sicherstellung der Auslandseinsätze oder
auch zur Aufrechterhaltung des Systems
Bundesheer
er Gelöbnis bedeutet die Bereitschaft
einen wertvollen Dienst für unsere
Heimat und für das österreichische Volk
zu leisten
sprechen Sie dieses Gelöbnis mit großem
Ernst und mit der Überzeugung eines
pflichtbewussten Österreichers
solartinnen und Soldaten ich weiß für
sie wird es nicht immer einfach sein
sich auf das neue Leben als Soldat
einzustellen
sie müssen Ihre individuellen
Bedürfnisse mit ihren kameradenabstimmen
Rücksicht nehmen und im eigenen Bereich
selbst für Ordnung sorgen viele von
ihnen sind zum ersten mal weg aus dem
Hotel Mama
sie sind Belastungen ausgesetzt
Belastungen bei Einsätzen bei der
Ausbildung und im täglichen
Dienstbetrieb aber glauben Sie mir
schwierige Situationen können mit
kameradschaftlicher Hilfe gemeinsam
leichter bewältigt werden und echte
Kameradschaft wird nicht selten zu
langen Freundschaften aber sie werden
auch stolz sein können auf sich selbst
stolz wenn Sie große Herausforderungen
wie lange Märsche
große Kälte oder in den vergangenen
Wochen große Hitze bewältigt haben jeder
von ihnen
leistet zu seinen Aufgaben des
Bundesheeres seinen wichtigen Beitrag wo
immer sind den kommenden Monaten auch
ihren Dienst versehen werden
ich möchte Ihnen daher dafür danken dass
Sie sich für die Erfüllung ihrer
Wehrpflicht beim Bundesheer entschieden
haben und ich danke Ihnen jetzt schon
für treuhändernis für die kommenden
Monate wünsche ich Ihnen beiden
Einheiten einen interessanten und
abwechslungsreichen Dienst und viel
Soldaten Glück
meine Damen und Herren
in Siegen sind ein zeichenstaatlicher
ständiger oder religiöser würde macht
und Auszeichnung und seit Jahrtausenden
nachvollziehbar im österreichischen
Bundesheer sind Fahnen und Standarten
sowie ehrensignalhörner und
ehrentrompeten eingeführte und
verwendete Insignien Insignien sollen
nach außen hin den Verband
repräsentieren und nach innen die
Verbundenheit sowie die
Zusammengehörigkeit das Soldaten und
Bediensteten zum Ausdruck bringen und
Stärken
dementsprechend kommt denn Insignien
auch in der gelebten Traditionspflege
des täglichen Dienstbetriebes und
spezielle Einsatz eine hohe Bedeutung zu
heute wird eine ehrentrompete zurück
übergeben sie wurde
1974 dem grenzschutzbataillon 201 in der
von der Gemeinde Fischbach gewidmet
dieses Bataillon wurde dann in das
leichte landwehrpathon 521 übergeleitet
wofür das Land bei stammregiment 52
mobil machens verantwortlich war heute
darf ich die ehrentrompete wieder an den
Kommandanten des nachfolgeverbandes den
Kommandanten des aufklärungs- und
artilleriepatron 7 übergeben und ich
bitte hierzu den Kommandanten und das
Feldzeichen zu mir
das ganze
zu Übernahme des ehrensignalhorns
insignum im Schritt Marsch
[Musik]
ich übernehme das ehrensignal haben
voller Freude und danke für die
rückübergabe
ich übergebe das ehrensignalhorn zur
sicheren Verwahrung
[Musik]
insignientrupp im Schritt Marsch
das ganze
es lebe das österreichische Bundesheer
es lebe unser Vaterland die Republik
Österreich in einem sicheren Europa ein
herzliches steirisches Glückauf
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja das war die Steiermark fantare
gewidmet der Steiermärkische
Landesregierung und bloss aus der Feder
von unseren
Militärkapellmeister ja wir freuen uns
ist das erste Mal bei unserer Angelobung
sie ist medial sehr präsent bis eine
richtige Powerfrau so wie ich sie immer
wieder medial erlebe und seit 19
dezember 2019 Mitglied der steirischen
Landesregierung zuständig für das Resort
Bildung Gesellschaft Gesundheit und
Pflege und wir freuen uns dass Sie heute
hier sind Landesrätin Magistra Doktorin
Juliane Bogner Strauss herzlich
willkommen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Militärkommandant
Herr Bürgermeister hohe Geistlichkeit
hohe Vertreterinnen und Vertreter der
Politik sehr geehrte Herren und
Festgäste geschätzte Damen und Herren in
Vertretung unseres Landeshauptmanns
Hermann Schützenhöfer gilt heute mein
besonderer Gruß aber den 423 jungen
Menschen und ich bin sehr freut dass
zumindest eine Frau dabei ist die heute
feierlich den Eid leisten werden der
Republik Österreich und insbesondere uns
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern dieser schönen
Heimat zu dienen
diese scheinbar aus der Mode gekommene
Begriff des Dienens im Dienste der
Allgemeinheit hat gerade einen
abgelaufenen für uns alles sehr
anstrengenden eineinhalb Jahren seinem
Wahrheit zeitloser Aktualität unter
Beweis gestellt und gerade das
österreichische Bundesheer dient mit
Bravour sie werden sich vielleicht
fragen warum ich als unter anderem es
wurde bereits erwähnt für Bildung
Gesellschaft Pflege und Gesundheit
zuständige Landesrätin diesen scheinbar
veralteten Begriff so hervorheben möchte
die Antwort ist eine ganz einfache
weil er in Wahrheit überhaupt nicht
veraltet ist er ist vielmehr ein Zeichen
von Selbstbestimmung von selbst
Behauptung und zeigt die Bereitschaft
für alles was in einer zivilisierten
Gesellschaft einen echten Wert darstellt
mit seinen Fähigkeiten einzustehen diese
Feststellung meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren mag ein wenig ungewöhnlich
klingen ganz besonders für Sie
geschätzte Recruiting und geschätzte
Rekruten weil sie im Rahmen ihrer
Ausbildung natürlich auch
Einschränkungen ihrer Freiheit
so wie wir sie alle erlebt haben in den
letzten eineinhalb Jahren und eventuell
auch Einschränkungen ihrer Freizeit
wahrnehmen werden die nicht immer lustig
sein können aber es gibt eben noch eine
andere Komponente die viel schwerer
wiegt es gibt nämlich im Zweifel keine
Rechte und auch keine Freiheit wenn man
nicht bereit ist dafür einzustehen dies
macht in letzter Konsequenz für alle
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher das
österreichische Bundesheer es gibt auch
keine Naturkatastrophe größeren Ausmaßes
die sich gewissermaßen von selbst wieder
wegräumt dies macht im Zweifel für alle
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher das
österreichische Bundesheer und wenn wie
im letzten Jahr geschehen während deiner
Pandemie sehr schnell und noch einmal
ein herzliches Danke an Sie Herr
Militärkommandant Personal für das
contact tracing gebraucht wird oder für
ähnliche Dienstleistungen
wer ist dann sofort zur Stelle es sind
die Soldatinnen und die Soldaten des
österreichischen Bundesheers obwohl es
ganz ganz sicher nicht zu den
militärischen Kernaufgaben gehört
Telefondienste oder ähnliches zu leisten
und dasselbe gilt und auch das hat mein
Ressort betroffen wie es heuer an der
Oberstein geschehen ist wenn kurzfristig
ein Pflegeheim wegen eines
coronabedingten komplettausfalls des
Personals weitergeführt werden muss
dann ist es auch dass österreichische
Bundesheer das zur Stelle ist und diese
Aufgabe perfekt übernommen hat warum er
wenig das weil wie ich soeben versucht
habe anhand dieser Beispiele zu
verdeutlichen diese Bereitschaft im
Zweifel ohne besonderen Dank und
Anerkennung ohne extra Bezahlung in
Notsituationen das Notwendige und
Richtige zu tun für das Funktionieren
unsere Gesellschaft einfach
unverzichtbar ist in diesem Sinne bin
ich sehr sehr freuen dass eine recruitin
und über 400 Rekruten heute Gelöbnis
leisten werden für uns alle für uns alle
da zu sein wenn es niemand anderer tut
dies ist eine ganz ganz besondere
Verantwortung
manch eine oder einer der heute zu den
angelobenen wird vielleicht schon später
oder wissen dass
für
berufssoldatinnen oder für einen
Berufssoldaten geeignet ist und diesen
Weg auch gerne einschlagen möchte
für diese jungen Menschen ist dieses
Bewusstsein des Dienens schon vorhanden
all jene die nach Ableistung des
Präsenzdienstes ihr berufliches Glück
anderweitig suchen werden wünsche ich
dass sie für die Zeit danach die
Erkenntnis mitnehmen dass
Selbstdisziplin
Kameradschaft und die Bereitschaft sich
dort solidarisch in den Dienst einer
wertvollen Sache zu stellen zeitlos
gültige Werte einer Gesellschaft
darstellen die sich selbst als
zivilisiert bezeichnet
in diesem Sinne möchte ich Ihnen alles
Gute wünschen und ich darf Ihnen jetzt
schon vorab für ein Einsatz im Dienste
unseres Landes und uns Bürgerinnen und
Bürger danken ein steirisches glück auf
herzlichen Dank zueinander
Gruppen werden jetzt gemeinsam und
lautstark vor ihnen das Treuegelöbnis
auf die Republik Österreich ablegen
hierzu wird der standartendruck vom
aufklärungs 7 hier sich in die Mitte des
Platzes geben für alle Medien mit Fahnen
spitz zur Truppe da findet die Akteure
vorstellen Kommandant und fangen
Offizier oberstleiten und Peter Braun
stand Datenträger Officer Stelle
Vertreter Rene Balz
ehrentrompetenträgerin die Frau oberstab
sagt Master Apollonia Fischer in der
pfannenoffice hier major Andreas
grassmugg vier Rekruten wurden vorher
stellvertretend ausgewählt
macht seine Dienst bei der ersten
aufklärungscompanie hier ein Feldbach
der Rekrut Eric Eder aus Mühldorf bei
Feldbach
ebenfalls in Feldbach bei der zweiten
panzerhaubitzenbatterie der Jan Zöhrer
aus Kirchberg an der Raab
aus St Michael beim jägerpartnern 18
dienstezeit der leon hat Gruber Stadler
aus Zeltweg und aus Graz von der ABC
abwehrcompan ist das 7 der Marko Kasper
aus Leibnitz ja und die
angelobungsformel spricht der Offizier
er Stellvertretern der Kommandant das
sieben jägerbrigade über 5.200 Soldaten
des aktiven millagestandes und sie will
Bedienstete und ich darf im bitten so
Vorsprechen ein stellvertretenden
Kommandant der sieben Jäger Brigade
Herrn Oberst Bernhard köfl herzlich
willkommen
[Applaus]
das ganze acht
zur Angelobung
in Sydney Blog im Schritt Marsch
in Siegen Block
halt eingeteilte Rekruten links und
rechts um
Rekruten zum Gewehr
meine lieben Angehörigen der 7 Jäger
das treue Gelöbnis ist laut und deutlich
nachzusprechen
ich glaube
mein Vaterland
die Republik Österreich
[Musik]
und sein Volk zu schützen
und mit der Waffe zu verteidigen
[Applaus]
ich gelobe
[Musik]
den Gesetzen
[Applaus]
und den gesetzmäßigen Behörden
Treue und Gehorsam zu leisten
[Applaus]
alle Befehle meiner Vorgesetzten
pünktlich und genau zu befolgen
und mit allen meinen Kräften
[Applaus]
der Republik Österreich
und dem österreichischen Volker
zu dienen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Rekruten vom Gewehr
ein geteilte Rekruten links und rechts
um
insignienblock im Schritt Marsch
[Musik]
das ganze rot
hier geschützt die Gäste ich habe euch
schon so 20 Minuten von 19 Uhr eine
besondere Überraschung versprochen in
Kürze wird erhoben Draht die Truppe
abtreten lassen wichtig ist dass ich ja
jeder seinen Sitz und Stehplatz merkt
nach dem abtreten dürfen Sie jetzt ist
20:03 Uhr die nächsten acht Minuten nach
vor zu ihrem Schützling können wir
dementellchen machen natürlich auch mit
unseren Ehrengästen mit der Frau
Landesrätin nützen Sie einfach die
Chance wenn sie hier ist
bitte abtreten lassen Herr
Oberstleutnant
die nächsten acht Minuten wir müssen die
kobitbestimmungen einlassen außer ein
bitte
das ganze acht
auf der Stelle abtreten der Asphalt ist
für Sie frei bitte
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
geschätzte Gäste wir müssen zurück sie
haben jetzt genau 120 Sekunden ihre
Sitzplätze wieder einzunehmen bitte wenn
Sie zurückkommen auf ihren Platz wieder
wir starten pünktlich in 120 Sekunden
mit dem weiteren Festakt mit dem großen
österreichischen Zapfenstreich
hoffe es hat da jeder das Bild als
Erinnerung mitgenommen
Dankeschön für Verständnis aber wir
müssen die cobitbestimmungen einhalten
sind alle die 3g-regeln eins von drei
haben sie erfüllt dankeschön
ja sie sind super in der Zeit wir haben
noch 90 Sekunden also es läuft wirklich
optimal
Fackelträger zum ausgabepunkt
ja fantastisch sie haben alle ihre
Sitzplätze ja sie haben gesehen in der
Zwischenzeit hat die Militärmusik
Steiermark damit sie es besser sehen die
großen
23 Minuten dauern es wirklich ein
Hochgenuss
gib mir seit 2 August erst wieder im
Dienst und schon so ein tolles Programm
drauf in Kürze werden hier die
Fackelträger einmarschieren
und dann wird der Herr Oberst Lackner
durchstarten zuerst mit der Konzert von
Feuerwehr und dann werde ich ihn zur
Lehrerin Überblick den Inhalt des Kursen
Österreichs großes Streiches etwas näher
bringen
so Fackelträger mal später einfließen
bei der Militärmusik sie kommen ja von
der ersten
aufklärungskompanie her aus Feldbach ja
die Fackelträger fließen deswegen ein um
die musikalische um zu beleuchten hier
als die Dunkelheit hier einbricht
ja wir starten musikalisch durch mit der
Konzert von Pfarre
[Musik]
[Applaus]
geschätzte Gäste in der Zwischenzeit
wird er bereit an der Bildbearbeitung
auf der rechten Seite von der Kirche
gearbeitet es werden hier bedienste der
aus Feldbach durchgehen sie bekommen
hier den QR-Code den einfach mit der
Kamera von ihren Handy runterladen und
Sie können dann unmittelbar nach der
Veranstaltung die ersten Bilder sind
schon drin jetzt ist noch die
Staatsfahne drin aber dann beim
Heimfahren einfach schauen laufen werden
hier Bilder gemacht und draufgeladen
also einfach abfotografieren und sie
sind hier ganz live dabei und natürlich
auch zu Hause sind alle live dabei ja
die Fackelträger fließen bereits ein
es sind 33
Rekruten von der ersten
aufklärungscompany aufgeklärt hat der
Lebertrans 7 und er spielt ebenfalls
normal bei der musikkommandant
Meister Martin Kurzweil ja in der
Zwischenzeit gebe ich ihnen Überblick
über den großen österreichischen
Zapfenstreich genießen Sie in Kürze die
würde die Größe am Fahren die innere
Ruhe diesen feierlichen
österreichischen Bundesheeres welche
besonderen Festtagen vorbehalten ist
erklingt heute als Anlass der
feierlichen Angelobung der jungssoldaten
hier in der Stadtgemeinde Feldbach vor
der wiederholt der Name Zapfenstreich
stammt aus der Zeit des Dreißigjährigen
Krieges in der ersten Hälfte des 17
jahrhunderts in den damaligen Feldlagern
ging es manchmal ziemlich laut und
lustig zu damit zu gegebener Zeit
im Lager am Abend Ruhe einkehrte wurde
vom Lagerkommandanten ein rumor Meister
eingeteilt dies hatte den Auftrag zu
genau festgesetzter Stunde für Ruhe und
Ordnung zu sorgen
als Zeichen seiner Würde druckt dieser
Mann einen Stock mit dem er den Zapfen
des Weinfasses schlug ab diesem
Zeitpunkt war der Ausschank verboten
diese Amtshandlung wurde zapfenschlag
oder Zapfenstreich genannt in den
ständigen Garnisonen der alt
österreichischen regimenta bietet es
sich der Brauch dass eine Trommlergruppe
durch die Straßen zog und mit diesen
Schlag das Zapfenstreiches den Soldaten
die Heimkehr Befall später wurde statt
der Trommlergruppe ein signalhornbläser
eingesetzt dieses Signal nannte man den
kleinen Zapfenstreich der große
österreichische Zapfen streicht den sie
heute ihren beinhaltet traditionelle
Melodien und historische österreichische
militärsignale
der erste Teil beinhaltet im
Wesentlichen den historischen Marsch aus
dem 17 Jahrhundert und das
signalzapfenstreich sowie die beiden
traditionsmärsche der Prinz Eugen Marsch
und otom in Österreich
der zweite Teil bringt religiöse
Melodien das niederländische Dankgebet
das Gebet vorderschlacht und vor allem
das Signal zum Gebet welches vom
Solotrompeter Wachtmeister Johann gross
aus der Ferne geblasen wird und zu den
schönsten dieser Art zählt
der dritte und letzte Teil bringt das
signalzapfenstreich das ebenfalls aus
der Ferne geblasen wird eine kurze
Überleitung lässt bereits das Thema der
bundeshymnen erkennen welche im
Anschluss aus Höhepunkt erklingt nach
dem abblasen sowie dem Abschlagen durch
das Orchester Ende der große
österreichische Zapfenstreich die
Militärmusik Steiermark und hat Leitung
des Militärkapellmeister wird zu Ehren
der angelobten Rekruten diese festliche
Abendmusik zur Aufführung bringen
[Musik]
das ganze
habt acht
[Musik]
das ganze
hat acht
ehrenzug
Pressen wird
Flagge wiederholen
zum wiederholender Flagge das ganze
rechts schaut
[Musik]
das ganze
habt acht
ehrenzug
Gewehr ab
das ganze rot
[Musik]
[Applaus]
danke schön fantastisch auf ihrem der
große österreichische Zapfenstreich ja
als letzten Punkt des militärischen
Protokoll meldete
Militärkommandant von Steiermark die
Beendigung die angelobungsfeier und das
Erfolg des abbieten weiterer Befehle
ehrenzug pressen
[Musik]
weiterer Befehle das ganze rechts schaut
herr Präsident
meldet die Beendigung des Festaktes und
bittet um weitere Befehle
ich danke gratuliere zu ausgezeichneten
Kommandoführung gratuliere allen
angetretenen Soldatinnen und Soldaten
zur ausgezeichneten exerzierleistungen
durch bedanke mich bei der Militärmusik
von dem schon heiß ersehnten großen
österreichischen Zapfen streichen bitte
Abdrücken jawohl Abrechnung
das ganze
ehrenzug
Gewehr ab
das ganze